okay it's time for hatred mail here's a
reminder about what hatred mail is
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so I'm calling today's
hatred mail a cuck behind a screen which
is kind of funny I feel like if there
was an unauthorized biography of me done
the antagonists might call it that the
David Pakman story a cuck behind a
screen okay that's the name of this
week's hatred mail but let's actually
listen to what this hatred had to say
now it's you Lib [ __ ]
there's turn to be in the crosshairs
good
I hope Trump six the IRS and you scum
like the Muzzy eight did to
conservatives he can start with you
Pakman than the Young Turks then the
nauseous Olbermann the worm turns
[ __ ] David Pakman you always be a
Chuck behind a screen I take issue with
that I'm a cocky Marat a screen right
the person watching is the [ __ ] behind
the screen or I guess I'm in front of
the camera I don't know you know it's
too bad that trumps going to come up
after us first before the Young Turks
and Keith Olbermann so we don't really
even to have a warning when it happens
yeah it just pops right up there it's
all happening clearly on hatred mail
remember you can turn hatred mail into
something positive by using the coupon
code hey tree at forty when you sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership it'll take 40% off that's
huge that is huge 40% off of your
membership if you use coupon code hey
tree at 40